here's what's going to happen I am going
to have to fix you manage you to on a
more personal scale a a more micro form
of management Jim what is that called
micro J boom yes now Jim is going to be
the client Dwight you going to have to
sell to him without being aggressive
hostile or difficult let's go all right
[Music]
fine hello hello this is Dwight shuit
from the dunder mlin Paper Company wow
that's great cuz I need paper excellent
then you are in luck because we are
having a limited time offer only on
everything wow this is my lucky day ask
him his name what is your name sir I am
Bill
butlicker really that's your real name
how dare you my family built this
country by the way be respectful Dwight
please oh yes Michael could you hold on
one second that's my other line what no
but I hello yeah no I'm just on the
phone with this stupid salesman he's so
dumb
probably just going to keep him on the
line forever not buy
anything okay it's up to you to change
his mind sorry that was a family
emergency oh no what's wrong you know
what that's private boundaries twight
come on I'm sorry Mr Butler as I was
saying we having a limited up a little
bit louder I'm hard of hearing he's hard
of he's an old man okay as I was saying
right now we are having talk louder okay
our prices have never been lower son you
have to talk louder never been lower
louder son buter our prices have never
been lower stop it stop it
he that is totally inappropriate you
never yell at the client you you listen
to me sir here we go the three words I
would describe you as is aggressive
hostile and definitely difficult Please
Mr am I rate right now please give me
another chance Mr but licker give me the
phone I have to put you on with my boss
well I should hope so who is this hello
this is Michael Scott regional manager
well this is William M butlicker hello
Mr but licker how may we help you
Michael I like the sound of your voice
you know what I'm going to do I'm going
to buy $1 million worth of paper
products
today see done thank you very much sir I
don't think you'll regret it you what I
did you are the master there is one
condition Michael yes you have to fire
the salesman that treated me so terribly
don't do it
Michael it's a million dollar
sale
[Music]
it's Britney
did you forget something what
happened to you guys give it
back the gift basket give it back what
is this it's real simple if you don't
appreciate what we do do then give us
back our basket maybe you should
leave yeah maybe we should maybe we
should leave come on let's leave but
before we leave my West friend and I are
going to wait for our cabs on your nice
couches can you call us a cab please I'm
going to oop sorry look my clothes are
so wet wet nice leather oh my shoes are
so muddy all right here you go take it
back it's been open yeah it was mine
What's missing
the turtles where are the turtles where
are the turtles come on guys get out of
here where are the
turtles where are they well guess what I
just drove my car into a lake you did
what this is the lake stop yelling at me
it's up there's no Road
here remain calm I have trained for this
okay exit the window here we go make a
uturn if possible look out for l
sh Michael are you okay swim for
it I got you I got
you
on I got you I got
you come on come
on come
on
I drove my car into a
lake oh I get it everybody knows about
the ultimatum yes I told
everyone
hey right back at you
what's your daughter's name again
pee peepa peepa how is she great great
well to be fair Jim
James jimothy to be fair jimothy the
that sounds weird are you okay with
being called Jim I am all right the
busiest Beaver award goes to Phyllis
lappin yeah way to go Phyllis nice work
per usual this says bushiest Beaver what
I told them busiest idiots it's fine but
we fix it we'll fix it up you don't have
to display that you know what today is
not a good day for a sales contest we're
we're not we're not doing this today
that doesn't seem fair you want to talk
about Fair does anyone need to smell my
old carpet you explain to me how that
was fair and I'll explain to you how
this is fair plus I just I think that
picking today was sort of taking
advantage but you're the one who picked
today I am a victim of a hate
crime Stanley knows what I'm I'm talking
about that's not what a hate crime is
well I hated it a lot okay I well I
managed my department and I've been
doing that for several years now and God
I've learned a lot of life lessons along
the way your Department's just you right
yes Jim but I am not easy to manage you
know your partner's got a lot of
attitude but I like that how long you
guys been dating Jim couldn't land me in
a thousand years but you're saying
there's a chance shut up seriously
you're going to sit in back uh yeah
that's the safest part of a car in the
event of a crash driver always protects
his side
first yeah that's no problem bam sure
uh-huh bam knock knock I'm on the phone
I know you are knock knock you can fax
it over yeah
5514 five L
0175 thank you bye-bye
it really makes us look unprofessional
they would never know it was me doing it
here we go knock
knock who's there Buddha Buddha who
Buddha the spread for me
whaton great I I need something to wipe
my head no there's there's butter on my
nothing it was a classic I got a knock
joke no God Michael please please please
please please let me all right KN KN
who's there KGB K VI asked the question
what the hell was that what are you
doing what are you doing hey hey stop it
stop it come on what are you doing mine
is part of a hilarious joke mine was
retribution what are you doing no more
knocknock jokes that's it ding dong
who's there
KGB do I get the door I'm not answering
the door the door no way it's the KGB
I'm not answering that yes you're going
you answer I'm not going to answer I'm
not going to answer it's the KGB the KGB
will fit for No
One
that's
true